loki not a threat  i beg your pardon  what i love about playing loki he plays  all the keys on the piano enough  see i can play the heavy keys too  something i always try and bring to  everything i do is digging into the  emotion i'm a god  you're a clown letting the characters be  ugly in a way for me it feels a bit more  real  glorious purpose the world that  production designers created is very  unique for  loki it has a lot of texture  thank god that loki and the mcu has a  sense of humor for inspiration  it was fun it was weird we were able to  create all these  bandit versions of loki's i feel like  i'm having an identity crisis  we have this amazing story that's  actually about coming to terms of who  you are  i feel very grateful that i'm part of a  project that i think has probably  changed the direction of the mcu and i  really want the fans to feel excited and  inspired about where we go next  [Music]  you